après dix mois d'abstinence les golfeurs
de 50 en yvelines ont pu à nouveau taper
la balle blanche ce samedi sur les
greens de l'albatros
le parcours était fermé pour travaux en
vue de la ryder cup 2018 pour fêter
cette réouverture les responsables du
centre ont organisé une journée baptisée
11 bouge avec des animations c'est de
dire aux gens ben voilà on ré ouvre on
est ouverts revenez découvrir parce
qu'il faut redémarrer la machine pour
nous on a on n'a pas pu accueillir ses
clients il faut en face une opération de
séduction pour qu'il revienne pour que
l'opération séduction fonctionne la
journée a débuté par un show
humoristique avec l'ancien golfeur de
l'european tour david edwards le sportif
a présenté à cette occasion ses
techniques
j'espère que les gens ont aimé mon show
et que tout le monde va chercher à
revenir encore au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya vraiment quelque chose de très
très spécialisés après le show les 1000
golfeurs présents pendant la journée on
puisse s'essayer à un concours de
précision trou numéro 11
le secteur était totalement remodelée
avec un lac et les difficultés ont été
modifiés on ne comprenait pas il est un
peu manche avant donc je trouve que trou
il a beaucoup changé est très grand très
grand
un plan d'eau beaucoup plus gros que la
normale est assez impressionnant les
professionnels découvriront le nouveau
parcours de l'albatros à l'occasion de
l'open de france
la compétition est programmée du 30 juin
au 3 juillet à 50 ans mme clinton